MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
Hi there, Welcome to Apps
Script Office Hours.
I'm Jan.
This is Ikai.
IKAI: Hi.
JAN: For those of you who
haven't joined us before,
Office Hours is chance where we
can tell you a little bit
about what's been going on in
Apps Script and go over
release notes, things
like that.
But we also have time to take
questions from you, either
live, if you've joined
us in the Hangout,
or on Google Moderator.
So if you go to
developers.google.com/live,
you can find the entry for this
Office Hours, and you can
find the link to post
questions on
Google Moderator there.
IKAI: And for those of your that
have joined us before,
you'll notice our fancy
new studio.
We're broadcasting live
from the rain forest.
But no, this is our first time
using new equipment, so we
apologize for a couple technical
difficulties that we
might stumble over.
But going forward, we're going
to have this fancy new studio,
so it's going really going to
make our stuff look really
cool, I think, really
high quality--
JAN: Make us look really cool.
IKAI: Yeah, and I get to live
out my childhood fantasy of
being Anderson Cooper.
So yeah, so let's get started.
JAN: All right, so the first
thing I do, I'm going to
switch over here to the Hangout,
and I'm going to
share my screen so that I can
walk you all through some
recent releases since our
last Office Hours.
So hopefully you can
see these now.
So I'm going to kind of
work backwards from
the most recent ones.
Last night, August 22, so we
fixed two issues that some of
you may have experienced.
The first one, where it was
happening with spreadsheets.
This only happen for a period
of about 24 hours, where if
you were making a copy of a
spreadsheet that had multiple
projects contained within it,
only one of those projects was
getting copied with
the spreadsheet.
That's resolved now, so it
should be working as expected.
Then the second issue was a
couple related things with the
script gallery, where installs
from the spreadsheet script
gallery were not installing
properly, either with an error
message or with no error message
but the script wasn't
showing up.
So that is fully resolved now,
as well, so you shouldn't have
anymore trouble there.
And then we had this regular
release on August 20 with a
few fixes and some improvements,
so I'll just run
through these quickly.
So now, UI App widgets have
set_style_attribute methods so
that you can set multiple
attributes at once instead of
calling set_style_attribute over
and over and over, once
for each attribute.
So that should help you reduce
the number of times you have
to call that in your code.
We also increase the maximum
file upload size in web apps
to 50 megabytes, so this now
matches the limit for the Docs
List service.
There is a new way of calling
logger.log now that allows you
to do string formatting.
This is actually really useful,
so definitely check
out the docs and see if that's
something that might help you
as you're kind of logging and
debugging your applications.
There's a few other fixes.
One was to the Date Picker
widget, where sometimes it was
having strange values if you
chose a date before 1970.
Another issue with All
Day Event Series.
They weren't being scheduled
properly for
certain time zones.
There's one with HTML
form elements.
It's causing those not to
be able to be sent in
google.script.run callbacks,
it's for HTML service.
Ikai, I think you have
some insight there.
IKAI: Yeah, we've been looking
at some reports that this is
still not working for some
people, so we'll be
investigating that, figure out
what's going on, if that's an
issue with the service, or if
that's just something else
that's making it really
confusing to figure out what
the source debug is.
That was one I was real looking
forward to because I
know that, going forward, we're
going to be supporting
HTML service a lot more.
We're going to be adding a lot
more new features and then
improving performance, so we
want to get that one working
because you can't
submit forms.
Make things hard.
JAN: So we'll get the rest of
that ironed out for anything
that might still be
happening there.
An issue with embedded charts
returning the wrong data type
was fixed, and then there was
also an issue with charts
where we were ignoring the
advanced parameters for data
source URLs.
And then finally, one that I'm
super excited about is we have
streamlined the process for
publishing apps to the Chrome
Web Store, so you no longer have
to go through the process
of doing the URL verification
through
Google Webmaster Tools.
That's just not required
for your apps anymore.
It's kind of taken care of
behind the scenes, so that
significantly streamlines
the process now.
It's about two clicks instead of
two clicks and some copies
and pastes and opening
back up again.
So definitely check that out
if you had gone through the
process before.
It's much, much smoother now.
OK, so one other thing I wanted
to mention before we
jump into questions.
Hopefully, you can
see this here.
There is a blog post that went
out today on the Google
Analytics blog, and also
cross-posted on the Google
Apps developers blog and the
Google developers blog,
announcing a really great script
that takes advantage of
the integration between
Apps Script and
Google Analytics now.
This blog post talks a little
bit about ways that you can
pull analytics data into Google
Spreadsheets really
easily, build custom
dashboards.
There's a great video explaining
how the script that
they've published in the
script gallery works.
And at the end, you'll notice
they also have something fun,
so the analytics team is
offering Google Analytics
developer t-shirts.
The first 15 developers who
build a solution that solves
some sort of business problem
using both the Google
Analytics API and Apps Script,
so check that out if you're
interested.
IKAI: I have the second
announcement, which is that if
you don't follow the blogs, we
announced that we will be
having an Apps Script
Hack-a-thon in Austin, Texas.
This will be on Thursday,
September 13, 2012.
So I will be there, I believe
Eric's going to be going, and
we'll have at least one other
team number coming.
There might be one or
two on the way, so
definitely sign up.
If you want to find the blog
post, it's at googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com, and
just scroll down.
Jan posted it about
a few day ago.
So just check it out, there's
a sign up form, and all the
information you need, so
hopefully we'll see you there.
And if not, we're looking at
doing some other cities at
some point in the future,
so we'll get your
city soon, some point.
JAN: OK, so let me pull up the
questions here, that we have
in Moderator.
All right, so looks like we
have two questions here.
The first one, let me read
through it, and then we'll
tackle each of these.
"Is it possible to add a control
to a geomap in order
to be able to choose what year
and month to view the data?
I've tried and failed
multiple times." You
familiar with what--
IKAI: Let me take a look at
this question real quick.
[INAUDIBLE]
to add--
well, Rusty, are you on
the chat right now?
Are you on the Hangout
right now?
Because I'd love to hear more
about what you're asking.
It's not quite clear to me.
JAN: Yeah, I'm not sure what's
being referred to as geomap
here, if this is something
related to the charts API, or
if this is something related
to the map service.
IKAI: Oh, could this be related
to fusion tables?
JAN: I'm not sure.
IKAI: OK.
JAN: I think what we're going to
need in this case-- let me
just see in the Hangout.
No, we don't have anybody typing
furiously in the chat
for the Hangout.
So I think we'll need a little
more details here.
I'll post a response afterwards,
trying to get some
more details about this
question, and then we can take
a look into it.
So the next one here, "Are
Google Apps Script dashboard
quotas by domain,
user, or script?
I received a too much traffic
error while posting three
large posts using URL Fetch app
eight minutes--" I guess
that's eight megs, four
megs, [INAUDIBLE].
"It appeared to be below
all publish quotas.
Why does this occur?"
So in most cases, the quotas
are going to be--
so it kind of depends
on the quota.
Some quotas are per user.
Some quotas are per user, per
script, so this URL Fetch one
is most likely going to be--
and then some quotas are
actually time based as well.
So some of them will be short
term quotas, so you can do x
amount of whatever that task
is or x amount of data
transfer in y amount of time.
So if this is a too much traffic
error, I'm guessing
that it's probably the amount of
bandwidth that you're using
in a small amount of time that
you're hitting, so again, this
would be a good one for us to
get a little more detail about
specifically what
you're doing.
It's also the case that the
dashboard is not exhaustive,
so it doesn't list every single
quota that exists.
We're trying to expand
what's listed there.
It lists most of them,
but not all of them.
So if there's a quote that
people are commonly running
into, we may need to add that
to the dashboard as well.
But I do believe that URL Fetch
does have some sort of
limitations around the amount of
data that you can transfer
or request in a given short
period of time, so if it's
possible for you to kind of
space that out a little bit,
that may help.
IKAI: I would suggest, at least
for purposes of testing
to figure out what exactly it
is, put a sleep between these
three things.
I'm not saying do this for your
production application,
just so we can I figure out
where you're hitting the
bandwidth limit.
I mean if you put, what, a 30
second, 60 second sleep, I
think that should be sufficient
to figure out if
it's because you're posting too
quickly or if you're just
going over some other limit.
Like there might be something
else going on, so we want to
narrow down what could be
tripping this limit.
Now--
Yeah, go ahead.
JAN: No, go ahead.
IKAI: I was going to say the
good news is that, going
forward, we are working on
raising a lot of the different
quotas, so it'll be a lot
harder trigger them.
But in the meantime, we want to
figure out what's causing
this, and we want to understand
what you're doing
with Apps Script so that, if it
makes sense to raise this
quote, and it sounds like it
does, that we can do so.
JAN: So another thing I would
like to know in this case is
for these requests that you're
making, if you're a Google
Apps customer, are they
within your domain?
So for example, are you
transferring things within--
files within your own domain
or something like that?
Because that may be different
use case than if you, for
example, you were making
requests out to some third
party API or from some third
party site where you have
files stored or something like
that, because there may be
different things that we can
do if this bandwidth is
constrained within your own
domain, if that makes sense.
So it'd be good to know just
a little bit more.
Oh, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I was using the
Apps Script to read those
three files out of Gmail.
They were attachments under an
email, and I was trying to
post them to our third party
collaboration system through
HTTP posts.
And I could successfully do it
with smaller files, just when
I got to the three bigger
ones in that use case,
it basically failed.
JAN: OK, so in that case, it may
be helpful for us to take
a look at ourselves.
We'll contact you afterwards to
get a little more details,
so we can try to reproduce
this and see specifically
which limit you're hitting and
see if we can give you some
possible solutions that
would work for what
you're trying to do.
AUDIENCE: OK, good, thank you.
JAN: OK.
All right, look like we had a
third one come in here while
we talking.
So "I'm using forms as a part
of my apps, and I was
wondering if there's a way to
get the user ID or email
outside my domain.
I wanted to get this information
so can prevent
users from submitting the
form multiple times."
So if you are using Google
spreadsheet forms, the built
in forms that are part of Google
Spreadsheets, no, I
don't think that's possible
unless you put a field
specifically asking the user
for their email address.
The only way that you can
automatically get that with
Google Spreadsheet forms as if
it's within your domain, and
you've enabled that option.
If you are using HTML service
or UI App or something like
that, and you have published
the web app to run with the
permissions of the user who's
accessing the app rather than
running as you the developer,
then you can actually call
session.get,
activeuser.get_email and get
their email address that way.
So that maybe another option
depending on how you're doing
this, but again, if you're using
a Google Spreadsheet
form, only if you're doing
that within your domain.
IKAI: And this is a little
bit of trivia.
Jan can actually write code
using speech to text as you
just demonstrated.
JAN: Wouldn't that be nice?
IKAI: Session dot use dot dot,
that was pretty good.
JAN: OK, do we have any
live questions?
AUDIENCE: Well, a couple of
questions that came up.
Very nice set, by the way.
It looks nice.
JAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the new Logger.
Did that--
[INAUDIBLE]?
IKAI: Oh, you're talking about
the bug where, when you do a
post, it doesn't log things.
I don't think we've
resolve this yet.
Eric, do you know if
we've resolved--
I don't believe that we've
actually fixed this bug.
I think that it's still--
JAN: We still have some work
that we're doing to get
logging working in web apps, so
that would include things
like doPost.
So we're still working
on that one.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool, because
it was working before
something got fixed.
IKAI: It was working, I think,
about a week and a half ago.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, about that.
JAN: There's some changes that
we need to make to get that
working again.
There's some other cases where
Logger is not currently
working in all cases, aside
from just doPost, so we're
actively working on that.
If I'm remembering correctly,
I think it's not going to be
too much longer before we'll
have that fix out for you.
So we'll definitely update
in the tracker once
it's actually confirmed.
AUDIENCE: Actually, that
reminded me of something.
One of the things that I would
do is I built my own little
Logger to just-- through
email because it was
nice and one liner.
One of the things that I've
noticed recently, and I
haven't distilled it down to
what the exact problem is, it
seems if you have Gmail Apps
and Mail, it's asking for
authorization a lot.
JAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I see you nodding,
so does that mean that
somebody's already tracked or
put that issue out there where
you're aware of it?
JAN: So that's actually
something that's very specific
to Gmail App, and it's
intentional because Gmail App
is one of these services
that's very, I guess,
sensitive could be the word.
I don't mean that in any way
capital S sensitive kind of
way, but it's--
AUDIENCE: Attractive
to people to abuse?
IKAI: No, no, no, I just
mean that it's
accessing your inbox.
It's one of the ones where we
want to be extra careful and
make sure that the user, the
person running the script,
knows what the script
is doing.
Any time you make a change to a
script that uses Gmail App,
it's going to prompt you for
authorization after any change
that you make it, so if you're
just using this for logging,
try Mail App [INAUDIBLE]
Mail instead.
Especially, if you're just using
it to send email, not to
read things from your inbox or
apply labels, Mail App may be
the way to go for you because
Mail App works a little
differently.
It's just for sending mail
instead of for accessing your
inbox and messages, you can
click that, so that will
probably save you a lot
of frustration.
IKAI: Another thing you can
do is you might build you
something in Spreadsheets
API or Script DB.
Now, the trade off is that it's
no longer a one liner,
but the good news is that if you
write this function once,
you could just go ahead and use
it in any other script you
write in the future.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's also the
advantage of the email, too,
is you get-- it's
instantaneous.
It was a little bit better than
Logger because you have
to run it and then
open Logger.
This was, you could have another
window running with
your email, and it
just pops up.
And if you put the information
you're looking for in the
subject line, it's really fast,
and they also the time
in there so it doesn't
end up in a thread.
So it's a different subject
line, and they just pop up.
It's really efficient
that way.
But I hadn't even really
mentally distinguished between
Gmail App and Mail App, so
that's kind of good.
So I probably should use Mail
App more often anyway for
other things as well.
Right?
For any time I'm
sending email?
JAN: If you're just sending
email, then it's probably the
simpler way to go, but if you
want to do anything around
accessing inbox threads or
messages or adding labels,
then you've got to go with
the Gmail service.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, I didn't
realize there was a
difference.
And then my last question was
is you mentioned that you're
coming to many different cities
for Hack-a-thons.
Any in Canada, Toronto,
or Montreal or Ottawa?
JAN: We don't have
any plans yet.
We actually don't have the rest
of our cities planned for
the rest of the year.
JAN: Right, we're still working
on it, although I will
tell you that some of the
Canadians here have been
trying to drag me to Montreal
for some time now.
JAN: I hear it's awesome.
IKAI: So I hear.
Not in the winter, so not any
time in the next few months.
No, we're thinking about it,
and since we're just in New
York City, we should just
be a bus ride away.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's true.
I'm down there fairly
often, so it might
be kind of fun to--
IKAI: I mean, it'd be a bus
ride for us to you.
Although it is a lot easier for
us to run events in New
York City, so we might just
do that to do that.
JAN: Yeah, we'll just have to
see how things go, but we'll
be sure to post them on the
Google Apps developer blog and
also on the
developers.google.com/events,
I believe it is.
Anything that we're hosting,
we'll end up posting there as
well, so that's a good
place to go.
That's for all of developer
relations, you can find our
events there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I've got all the
notices for the others, so
it's all pretty cool.
JAN: OK.
One other thing that I wanted
to mention when you were
talking about logging
and debugging.
So if you're running your
scripts from the editor, and
you want just a quick way
to throw up some debug
information onto the screen, you
can also just use Throw.
And I use it sometimes instead
of logger.log when I just want
to do something quickly.
If you throw something, and
then give it the string of
whatever you want to display,
you'll get this
red bar at the top.
So basically, you'll be throwing
an exception, but
then if you click the details
link from there-- it's a very
dirty way of doing things.
You can click the details link
from there, and then whatever
you have thrown will
show there.
And it can actually--
I think that it'll buffer more
text than Logger currently
will, so sometimes if I've got
a big chunk of text that I
want to log, I will sometimes
use Throw.
IKAI: But it also
stops execution.
JAN: Oh, yeah.
IKAI: If you want that.
JAN: If you want that, then
it gets the job done.
AUDIENCE: Well, generally, when
I'm putting it in, I've
got a problem, and I need
to find something.
So the fact that it
stops there--
it was stopping around
there anyway, so
that's kind of cool.
Thank you for that.
IKAI: Have you used
a debugger at all?
AUDIENCE: I have.
But the last little while,
I've been doing a
lot of UI app stuff.
Unfortunately, it
doesn't really
do what I need because--
JAN: Well, hopefully, soon we'll
have the logger working
again for you in web apps,
and that'll get you
back on your way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, debugger,
if there's some
possible way that--
I can't envision it.
That's why I've never actually
asked for it as a feature.
If there's some possible way
that you could kind of, as a
UI app was running, you could
get the variables, you know
just the values and the
variables, that
would be kind of neat.
Or like a real time logger, if
you could open a window.
Actually, maybe I should
do that as a feature,
enhancement.
IKAI: That would be a good
feature, not just for UI
service, but also for HTML
service and anything that has
a, we call head, non-headless
apps.
JAN: Yeah.
I guess the question would be,
then, which instance of it are
you attaching to.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IKAI: Oh, no, we're talking
about that when you attach
debugger to UI.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see, debugger.
IKAI: Because the difference is
that, yeah, you could have
multiple people attaching to
multiple GUIs, and which one
would you attach to, right?
So--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --logger might help,
too, because you could
essentially do that.
If you could open a Logger
window, rather than waiting
until the end, wherever Logger's
being written, that
you have a real time Logger
window because what I often
will do is I'll define
my own variable.
So if I've got i, I'll have i
equals and then put the value
in my Logger, so I know what
value's being displayed.
If you had a real time Logger,
whenever Logger wrote to it
that it would display in that
window, you wouldn't
necessarily get the debugger in
the sense that you stopped
the code, but you would
real time be able to
see what was happening.
JAN: Yeah, definitely put it
in the issue tracker and we
can have the engineering team
take a look and see if it's
something that'd be feasible
for them to do some time in
the future.
The answer might be that it's
not, but we'll be happy to
look into it for you at least.
IKAI: Or my ideal world answer
is that it is, but as part of
a greater framework of
log enhancements.
Like right now, as you know, the
Logger's only good for the
one execution.
I mean, you might want a logger
that lasts a few days
or whatever.
Right?
JAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Cool.
JAN: OK, so we have a couple
more minutes here.
Any other live questions that
we can jump back over?
And I'll check and see if
we've got anything more.
Oh, look at that, we have a
couple other questions.
IKAI: Oh, wow.
JAN: I'm going to have to go
back to screen sharing here.
IKAI: We're popular
hours today.
I mean--
JAN: So let's see how much
we can get through--
let me pull this screen
back up--
in the next two minutes.
All right, so Script DB--
OK, so this question about
Script DB being quota'd.
Does it count against the script
author's drive quote?
So it says "Script DB counts
against script author's drive
quota, but where can the quota
be queried and viewed?"
So actually, I think that it's
not the drive quota that it's
counting against, if I
remember correctly.
IKAI: I think there's just
a Script DB quota.
JAN: Specific script DB quota,
and we don't currently have a
way for you to query directly
how much you've used.
I think, there is a feature
request in for that.
I'm pretty sure.
If there's not, definitely
raise one.
So that's something that we
do acknowledge a need for.
We have also heard requests to
have Script DB quota be tied
to drive quota, but it currently
is not today.
"So I've noticed that logger.log
doesn't work inside
callback functions." Yes,
that is the bug we were
referencing, where Logger is not
currently working in web
apps and in a couple
other cases.
We're working on it, and it
hopefully won't be too much
longer before we have that
fixed up and rolled out.
IKAI: That is not intentional
behavior.
JAN: Right, so the team is
working hard on that.
And then I have two questions
about components.
One, "Is there a way to get the
selected item on a list
box from another component's
click event?"
And two, "Set_tag isn't working
inside callback
functions when I set it and try
to get that null at the
same time." So that last
question would be one that
would be really great for us
to get on Stack Overflow,
along with a snippet of code
of the script that you're
running that's seeing this
behavior because that will
help us take a look and give
you some suggestions better
than we can kind of doing
30 seconds right here.
But that's definitely a UI
app question that we
can take a look at.
If you post it on Stack
Overflow, we or another app
script person will
take a look.
IKAI: And I want to say hi to
Marcello, who is one of our
GDG organizers in Bolivia.
JAN: Awesome.
IKAI: So how you doing?
Welcome to the Hangout.
And he's not on the
live video, so he
can't say hi back.
JAN: Well, hi from us, to you.
OK, I think we're out of time,
so thanks for joining us, and
we'll be back next week.
I also want to mention that next
Friday, we have a special
additional session where we're
doing, instead of Office Hours
on Friday, we'll be doing kind
of a chat interview style
format with a external Apps
Script developer, Andrew
Stillman, who has actually
written a lot of the popular
scripts in the script gallery.
So it's on the calendar for
Google Developers live.
Be sure to join us if
you're interested.
All right?
IKAI: All right, and
that's a wrap.
We'll see you here next time.